du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
elle a une premier sommet du g7 pour
votre job hayden réunions virtuelles
pandémie oblige comme attendu le
président américain s'est érigé en
défenseur de démocratie dans son viseur
la russie et l'iran au menu également le
comique 19 les puissances du g7 ont
annoncé
celle de 2,5 milliards de dollars à la
vaccination anti copie d
au paraguay le premier lot du vaccin
spoutnik v est arrivé aujourd'hui 4000
premières doses livrées par la russie
sur les 1 millions commandées via le
programme kovacs le pays en attend plus
de quatre minutes supplémentaires
[Musique]
la situation épidémique en france et ce
paradoxe si les indicateurs sont à la
baisse la circulation des nouveaux
variants continue de progresser 12,7
nouvelles mesures annoncées hier par
audi général isolement des personnes
testées positives et porté de 7 à 10
jours
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france on commence avec
le sommet virtuel du g7
aujourd'hui une première pour un job
hayden sans surprise le président
américain s'est érigé en défenseur des
démocraties il a mis en garde contre un
retour au bloc figée de la guerre froide
dans son collimateur la russie est la
bête noire des etats-unis l'iran sur ce
dernier point pas de rupture avec son
prédécesseur à donald trump ont fait le
point avec walid bennani des mesures
diplomatiques pour sauver un accord
nucléaire important pour les équilibres
internationaux etats unis iran la guerre
des mots et le poids des hamdan puis
châteauroux les paroles et les promesses
sont inutiles cette fois ci des actes de
l'action et si nous voyons des actes de
la part de la partie en face alors nous
agirons aussi la république islamique ne
se contentera pas cette fois-ci de
parole et de promesses que nous ferons
ceci ou cela ce ne sera pas comme avant
nous avons toujours dit que nous
attendons de l'iran qu'il respecte à
nouveau les engagements qu'il a suspendu
petit à petit et que nous sommes prêts à
l'aider en tant qu'européens et que
d'autre part la politique de sanctions
qu'il ya eus sous le présent trump
appartient également au passé
aujourd'hui les plus grandes nations du
monde sont concernés après une
concertation entre français britannique
allemand et américain
washington a accepté de participer à de
futures négociations avec l'union
européenne et téhéran dans l'espoir de
raviver des accords de 2015 il s'agit de
s'asseoir à une table avec l'iran et
ouvrir une voie pour essayer de revenir
à une situation où les états unis et
guirand seront à nouveau en conformité
l'administration maiden a donc décidé de
rompre avec les dernières mesures prises
par donald trump et son souhait d'un
renforcement des sanctions
internationales contre la république
islamique
une lettre a été adressée ainsi en ce
sens au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
le département d'état a annoncé
également jeudi que les diplomates
iraniens seront désormais autorisés à se
déplacer librement à new york ce
vendredi le ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères a réitéré son appel
à une levée de toutes les sanctions
imposées par l'ancien président
républicain les etats unis ont reconnu
que les revendications de mac pompéo
concernant la résolution 22 30 et une
n'avait aucune validité juridique
nous sommes d'accord en conformité avec
la résolution 22h31 les états unis
lèvent sans condition et de manière
effective toutes les sanctions
prononcées réimposer ou réétiqueter par
trump nous annulerons alors
immédiatement toutes les mesures
correctives
l'objectif de washington empêchait
toujours l'iran d'enrichir de l'uranium
dans le but d'acquérir une arme
nucléaire téhéran qui a annoncé cette
semaine mettre fin aux inspections
surprise de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique dans le cadre de
l'accord de 2015
le directeur de l' agence onusienne est
attendu ce samedi dans la capitale
iranienne
des diplomates iraniens désormais
autorisés à se déplacer librement à new
york vous l'avez entendu et ce matin
c'est un réaction russe écouter dimitri
peskov le porte-parole du kremlin
nous sommes un pays qui a réaffirmé à
maintes reprises son engagement en
faveur du plan d'action global commun
sur l'iran nous avons toujours déploré
que les états unis se soient retirés du
jcp aux as
par conséquent nous appuyons toujours
sans réserve ce document et appelons
tout le monde à faire tout son possible
afin de le mettre en oeuvre
les dirigeants du g7 a bien sûr évoqué
la pandémie de covile 19
ils ont annoncé un soutien de 7 5
milliards de dollars à la vaccination
contre le collier 19 il plaide en faveur
d'une collaboration étroite entre les
états dans ce communiqué
nous allons travailler ensemble avec les
autres pour faire de 2021 en tournant
pour le multilatéralisme et pour
façonner une reprise qui promeuvent la
santé la prospérité de nos peuples et de
notre planète
emmanuel macron au chevet de l'afrique
le président français a proposé que
l'europe et les états unis livre le plus
vite possible 13 millions de doses de
vaccin au continent pour qu'ils puissent
vacciner ses 6,5 millions de soignants
on écoute le continent africain à 6,5
millions de soignants il faut 13
millions de doses de vaccins pour les
protéger permettre au système de soins
de résister si nous européens américains
nous avons livré le plus vite possible
c'est 13 millions de doses ça vaut
énormément ça vaut notre crédibilité
ça représente 0,43 pour cent des doses
que nous avons commandé
si nous savons faire ça alors l'ouest
aura une présence et sera considérée en
afrique
si nous annonçons des milliards
aujourd'hui pour donner des doses dans
six mois dans huit mois dans un an
nos amis africains auront sous la
pression de leurs populations et à juste
titre acheté des doses aux chinois ou
aux russes ou directement à d'autres
laboratoires et le msc félicité des
annonces du g7 pour lutter contre la
pandémie dans le monde on écoute le
patron de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
nous avons besoin que les gouvernements
financent entièrement le kovacs et
qu'ils fassent des dons maintenant nous
sommes reconnaissants des annonces
faites aujourd'hui par plusieurs pays du
g7 dans l'équité en matière de vaccin
n'est pas seulement la bonne chose à
faire c'est aussi la chose intelligente
à faire d'autres vaccins sont en cours
de développement d'approbation et de
production il y en aura assez pour tout
le monde mais pour l'instant les vaccins
sont une ressource limitée
nous devons les utiliser aussi
efficacement que possible un sommet du
g7 pas comme les autres la crise
sanitaire a largement dominé les
échanges écoutez l'analyse
gérard abbé pierre léger ou politologue
chercheur associé à la ferme ou la
fondation pour le moyen orient
on est à une réunion maintenant qui va
stage indart entre le co vide la relance
économique
hier la situation donc qu'ils étaient
générés par le ralentissement de la et
l'invasion du de la pandémie a donc vous
avez le dossier iranien que vous avez
évoqué à la situation bien sûr vis-à-vis
de la russie
donc des dossiers très importants où il
va y avoir à une plus grande cohérence
est beaucoup moins de tension qui avec
les incertitudes représenté par le
précédent gouvernement américain au
cours de l'année 2020 l'axé nation
toujours spoutnik v est arrivé ce matin
au paraguay la russie a livré les 4000
premières doses du vaccin et le pays en
un commandaire millions plus de quatre
millions supplémentaires sont attendus
via le programme kovacs mise en place
par l' oms pour les pays en
développement est la priorité est donnée
aux soignants les premiers bénéficiaires
vont être les médecins de l'unité de
soins intensifs
nous parlons des médecins et du
personnel infirmier mais aussi du
personnel de soutien et de l'aide au
diagnostic
les personnes qui prélèvent
habituellement les échantillons par
ippon visionnage en outre nous allons
également touché les personnes qui
travaillent dans les pavillons de
secours
écoutez à john de grosses quilles le
directeur général du washington post à
amine de soins with you hell voilà ce
qui fut fait et comment la géopolitique
fonctionne écouter quand les pays
d'amérique latine et africains reçoivent
une aide alimentaire
on sait bien étiqueter fabriqué aux
états unis
on fait ça tous dedans c'est le vaccin
sur est un nouvel enjeu géopolitique
pour augmenter son influence en amérique
latine c'est un jeu d'échecs un jeu à
somme nulle
ce que gagne 1 quand l'autre le père du
coup les pays occidentaux l'union
européenne ont peut-être l'impression
que les états unis.vers de l'amérique
latine parce que la russie y gagnent du
terrain en france les indicateurs
donnent des signes d'amélioration mais
la circulation des variants continue
d'inquiéter doux l'allongement des
lundis de la durée des allemands de cet
as du jour pour les personnes a
contaminé une annonce hier soir olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé et ce
matin gabriel attal a réagi à la
proposition lui du conseil scientifique
de privilégier un auto isolement pour
les personnes âgées il n'est pas
convaincu
écoutez le porte-parole du gouvernement
demandez à notto isolement des personnes
les plus âgées semblent être très
compliqué il faut voir à quoi cela
correspond et si c'est efficace
il n'y a pas eu l'efficacité prouvée
d'une telle mesure il n'y a pas de pays
dans le monde qui ne confine qu'une
génération et pas les autres
c'est la république en marche divisée
face à la gestion de la l'épidémie dans
une lettre adressée au premier ministre
plusieurs députés prennent position pour
une sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
estime qu'il a trop duré et qu'il mais
je cite la démocratie en péril
on voit cela avec nadège abderrazak nous
sommes devant l'assemblée nationale le
là où une dizaine de députés de la
république en marche ont interpellé le
premier ministre dans une lettre que
l'opposition aurait largement pu signer
il tape du poing sur la table
ces députés dénoncent le maintien de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et par le
même de 300 jours de régime d'exception
l'état d'urgence permet l'extension
quasi illimitée des prérogatives de la
puissance publique et la réduction
drastique des libertés fondamentales
la liberté doit demeurer en toutes
circonstances le principe et la
restriction l'exception il est de notre
responsabilité de vous alerter sur ce
qui semble constituer à nos yeux un
danger réel pour notre démocratie un
danger réel pour notre démocratie vous
aurez peut-être du mal à le croire mais
les propos sont signés de députés
affiliés à la majorité présidentielle
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
instauré pour la première fois en france
le 24 mars 2020 sur l'ensemble du
territoire suite à la crise lié à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 ce régime
d'exception et permet des restrictions
plus étendue que l'état d'urgence
classiques qui visent à lutter contre le
terrorisme
il permet par exemple au préfet de
prononcer des interdictions de sortie
des fermetures d'établissements et des
mesures de quarantaine ou des
réquisitions il permet également au
gouvernement de légiférer par ordonnance
c'est à dire sans débat parlementaire
avec la mise en place d' audience à huis
clos et à juge unique en matière pénale
c'est le cas par exemple avec le conseil
d'état qui est devenu l'organe de
décision central du président de la
république
d'autres risques qu'ils soient
sécuritaires sanitaires sociaux
économiques ou climatiques se
succéderont et nous mettrons
collectivement à l'épreuve sans qu'il
soit souhaitable de vivre en permanence
dans un état d'exception justifiée par
l'urgence un état d'exception ne saurait
devenir la règle sauf à dénaturer nos
institutions et porter atteinte au bon
fonctionnement de notre vie démocratique
nous appelons à ce que le bon
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
parlementaire ne devienne pas une
victime collatérale des menaces qui
pèsent sur nos sociétés
les signataires proposent d'inscrire
dans la constitution et le régime de
l'état d'urgence
inscriptions qui permettrait d'y
intégrer je cite de solides garde-fous
en matière de protection des libertés
fondamentales
il est nécessaire de définir et
d'expliciter la composition l'émission
les prérogatives et le contrôle des
instances de décision qui comme le
conseil de défense n'ont pas aujourd'hui
d'existence institutionnels ce qui
alimente chez un bon nom
de nos concitoyens l'idée d'une certaine
forme d'opacité voire de défiance
ces critiques sont depuis des mois
martelait par l'opposition et elles sont
désormais partagés au sein de la
majorité présidentielle
la s'est elle aussi fait de n'être
consulté que pour la forme
cette prise de position des députés a
l'air om peut surprendre
peut-être faut-il y voir un signe l
approche des échéances électorales
en espagne trois jours après
l'arrestation du rappeur pablo hazell la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas de
nombreuses violences ont éclaté en marge
de manifestations de soutien
le bilan de plusieurs dizaines
d'arrestations a les détails c'est avec
à mahdia s'oublie la nouvelle avait
embrasé l'espagne mardi dernier le
rappeur pablo à celle a été condamné à
neuf mois de prison pour injure à la
couronne et aux institutions de l'état
ainsi qu'à pau logis du terrorisme en
cause des dizaines de tweets publiés
entre 2014 et 2016
l'information a rapidement mené à des
manifestations musclées dans le
plusieurs grandes villes du pays
les espagnols se mobilisent et
revendique la liberté d'expression
chantage dire expliqué et criait ça ne
peut jamais être condamné parce que
sinon on est dans une répression est un
problème est creux nous mène nulle part
pablo à celle avait jusqu'au vendredi 12
février pour se livrer à la justice mais
il s'est barricadé dans l'université de
la ville catalane de lérida mardi soir
pour échapper à la prison
la police l'a délogé et immédiatement
incarcéré depuis les manifestations en
soutien au chanteur engagé prennent de
l'ampleur
des milliers de personnes défilent
chaque soir pour condamner la censure
son avocat souligne que son client n'est
pas le premier artiste à payer pour ses
prises de position c'est l'un des pays
ont beaucoup d'artistes ont été
condamnés à des peines de prison
ce qui n'est pas acceptable nous avons
d'autres problèmes politiques et sociaux
dans le contexte de la pandémie la
récession économique est une question
cruciale puisque les jeunes n'ont aucun
avenir
elle offre aux ménages mais qu'elle n'en
aille au fond tout lors les forces de
l'ordre largement déployées ont dû
intervenir à plusieurs reprises a pris
de nombreux débordements incendie et
violences en marge des marches
pacifiques
des dizaines de personnes blessées parmi
lesquelles des policiers
les ministres espagnol a condamné toute
sorte de violence il n'y a pas
d'exception à la règle
il n'y a pas de cause ni de lieu ni de
situations qui puissent justifier le
recours à la violence
aucune précisément parce que la violence
n'est pas une liberté
c'est une atteinte à la liberté des
autres la violence est une attaque
contre la démocratie et par conséquent
le gouvernement espagnol se posera
toutes formes de violence et garantira
la sécurité des citoyens
là j'ai voulu apurer en catalogne la
police régionale a interpellé 33
personnes à madrid où des centaines de
personnes rassemblées sur la place de la
puerta del sol réclamé je cite la
liberté pour pablo
la police a fait état de dix neuf
arrestations si le capable osl provoque
un soulèvement populaire
il divise également la coalition au
pouvoir en effet à l inverse du premier
ministre socialiste espagnol
le parti d'extrême gauche podemos a
affiché son soutien aux manifestants en
algérie le retour du président fait du
bruit abdelmajid tebboune est resté
longtemps absent la suite d'une
hospitalisation en allemagne pour
soigner des complications post co vide
il promet maintenant la dissolution du
parlement appelle à des législatives
anticipées et libère des militants tout
cela pour contenir la contestation
populaire à quelques encablures du
deuxième anniversaire du irak
françois tessier beach
son discours à la nation était très
attendu de retour d'allemagne il ya
plusieurs jours après avoir été soigné
pour des complications post co vide
pendant plusieurs semaines abdelmadjid
tebboune multiplient les annonces pour
calmer la fronde politique et sociale
qui couve dans le pays j'ai décidé d'un
remaniement ministériel dans les 48
heures en cours mais je l'annoncerai
demain ou après demain et il inclura
tous les secteurs est les citoyens ainsi
que nous estimons qu'il ya un manque de
performance
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale populaire pour appeler à des
élections qui soient franchies de
l'argent qu'ils viennent de la
corruption ou non et d'ouvrir les portes
à la jeunesse des annonces qui
interviennent après des consultations
menées avec six formations politiques le
week-end dernier
autre geste d'apaisement la grâce
présidentielle accordée une cinquantaine
de militants du irak dont une trentaine
condamnés en début de semaine à des
peines allant jusqu'à deux ans de prison
ferme
j'ai décidé d'accorder la grâce
présidentielle à une trentaine de
personnes environ à l'est pour
lesquelles une décision avait été rendue
et d'autres pour lesquels aucun verdict
ce n'avait été rendu à wallace crevé à
lembach entre 55 et 60 personnes
rejoindront à partir de ce soir ou
demain leurs familles
chara d'un état
cette mesure survient à quelques jours
du deuxième anniversaire du airaq ce
mouvement de protestation populaire
déclenchée en février 2019 et qui a
forcé abdelaziz bouteflika la démission
deux mois plus tard à l'arrêt depuis
mars 2020 en raison de la pandémie les
mobilisations se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours comme le 16 février à
kherrata berceau du mouvement
enfin dernières annonces du président
algérien
la production du vaccin rue spoutnik v
contre locaux vides 19 d'ici six mois
avec pour objectif de faire vacciner
vingt millions d'algériens soit la
moitié de la population du pays d'ici la
fin de l'année et de nouveaux défis
attendent le gouvernement selon ali
benouari le président du parti algérien
l'ida el watan la libération d'opinion
même si le mode et d'une opinion elle la
prend dans c est à saluer et puis
c'était d'ailleurs une des
revendications de la quasi totalité de
la classe politique ou de ce qui tient
lieu de classe politique
donc cet axe était un préalable et je
pense que le président a bien compris
que rien ne peut se faire tant que des
détenus d'opinion sont encensant garder
hors jugement ou après des jugements
expéditifs
c'est une crise à la fois politique
économique sociale morale générationnel
et tout cela sur fond de crise sanitaire
louer les défis sont immenses pour le
prochain gouvernement
donc je ne sais pas quelle sera sa
composante
quelles seront ses missions mais en tout
cas que de gens peu d'observateurs
pensent que un gouvernement quel qu'il
soit nommé dans ces conditions là que
résoudre les problèmes qui se posent aux
algériennes nouvel attaquant en
république démocratique du congo quatre
personnes ont été tuées dans la province
du nord-kivu
jeudi dans la soirée est les autorités
accusent une nouvelle fois le groupe
armé forces démocratiques alliées on
voit cela avec un rossi wiki et maxime
abolin la république démocratique du
congo de nouveau endeuillé seulement
quelques jours après un premier massacre
qui a fait 10 morts
le pays a subi une nouvelle attaque des
actes qui semble être l'oeuvre des
rebelles de l'adf groupes armées
ougandaises implantée dans la région de
béni depuis 1995 ce jeudi aux alentours
de 21h des hommes armés ont ouvert le
feu sur les civils dans cet événement
malheureux
nous avons enregistré de perte en vie
humaine
là il faut citer quatre personnes et
parmi ces personnes deux femmes et deux
hommes pour le moment nous avons aussi
enregistré le cas de dean dame blessée
il ya aussi des personnes portées
disparues ce qu'elle a auprès des trois
le bilan s'alourdit pour un mois de
février déjà meurtrier plus de 50
personnes ont perdu la vie dans des
attaques présumées de l'adf et pour
éviter une nouvelle perte les équipes
médicales de l'hôpital d'auch licha met
tout en oeuvre pour sauver la femme
blessée dans l'attaqué
d'abord relevé ni dans un état de choc
parce qu'elle avait déjà perdu beaucoup
de sang et nous l'avons stabilisé et on
a donné beaucoup des liquides et nous
l'avons même transfuge la été touchés
latif al assi been fractures au niveau
des ligneris droit et
et in fact nouvelle tu es une autre
fracture au niveau du pérou la situation
reste très tendue dans la région de béni
à l'est de la république démocratique du
congo
et si l'armée a entrepris une opération
d'envergure fin 2019 pour déloger les
rebelles de l'adf
elle n'a pas permis leur dissolution
depuis elle les combattants agissant
petits groupes mobiles pour tenter
d'endiguer définitivement ces tueries
successives
l'armée congolaise a lancé une campagne
de recrutement largement entendu par la
population en birmanie à une première
victime après le coup d'état de l'armée
il s'agit d'une manifestante de 20 ans
blessé par balle à la tête lors d'une
manifestation la semaine dernière elle a
succombé à ses blessures son corps fera
l'objet d'une autopsie la birmanie
qu'est ce que depuis le 1er février
dernier à la suite d'élections
législatives contestées l'armée à un
birman qui a interdit depuis tout
rassemblement de plus de cinq personnes
dont les principales villes du pays et
l'accès chef du gouvernement ou santschi
est toujours assigné à résidence
en australie facebook bloc l'information
à l'heure où l'influencé des réseaux
sociaux est de plus en plus critiqué une
décision prise à quelques jours de
l'adoption par le parlement d'une loi
visant à contraindre les plateformes
numériques à rémunérer les éditeurs de
presse pour la reprise de leurs contenus
les précisions avec antoine ogi le ton
monte entre facebook et canberra
refusant de payer les groupes de presse
pour la diffusion de leurs contenus
la firme de mark zuckerberg a interdit
depuis mercredi les 16 à 18 millions
d'utilisateurs que compte le pays
d'accéder au contenu des médias locaux
et internationaux
une initiative unilatérale qui fait
grincer des dents du côté du
gouvernement du libéral scott morrison
facebook aux roms facebook a eu tort
facebook
les actions de facebook n'était pas
nécessaire elles ont été sévères et cela
va entacher leur réputation ici en
australie
est-ce que les événements d'aujourd'hui
confirment pour tous les australiens
c'est l'immense pouvoir qu'ont ces
géants des médias numériques sur le
marché hors weiss
mais il y a ted rogers pour le réseau
social le projet de loi ne tient pas
compte des accords qui unissent le pays
et la firme déclare je cite faire face à
un choix désagréable en cessant
d'autoriser les contenus à caractère
informatif cette décision pose problème
aux médias australiens puisque en les
empêchant de diffuser sur facebook
elle leur enlève une part d'audience non
négligeable et laisse la part belle au
feq news pourtant les habitants du pays
semble prendre parti pour la firme de
mark zuckerberg
je pense vraiment que c'est la faute de
nos gouvernements
je ne pense pas que nos lois devraient
être faites pour restreindre les marchés
comme ça
quoi qu'il en soit google a aussi été en
conflit avec eux il ya quelques temps je
pense que facebook d'une certaine
manière composition contre le
gouvernement australien
je ne soutiens pas facebook mais je
pense qu'ils font la bonne chose dans
cette affaire
je pense que ce que fait le gouvernement
n'est pas juste je veux dire il essaie
de faire de l'argent et cela profite
plus aux agences de presse qu gens en
général certaines applications sont
payantes
d'autres noms facebook et gratuit donc
si c'est gratuit tout ce qui est sur
facebook doit être gratuit le conflit
entre le géant californien et l'état
australien pourrait avoir de fâcheuses
conséquences pour la population puisque
les pages d' alerte en cas de feux de
brousse de cyclones ou d'épidémie ont
elles aussi un temps de cesser de
fonctionner la page facebook du bureau
of meteorology a été affecté par les
restrictions soudaine du contenu des
actualités facebook les informations
météo sont toujours disponibles sur
baume point gogh point haut et sûr le
baume application météo des pages
gouvernementale désactivé par erreur
d'après facebook qui a déjà commencé à
les restaurer alors que le ministre des
finances georges frydenberg a déclaré
jeudi qu'il s'était mis d'accord avec
les violets dg de facebook pour trouver
un terrain d'entente
la ferme et en lumière le déséquilibre
financier qui se creuse entre les géants
du web et les médias dits traditionnels
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais eu